digamos que tenemos una curva r y que
vamos a parametrizar de la siguiente
forma tenemos su vector de posición o su
función vectorial de posición
digamos r que depende de t va a ser
igual a equis de t en la dirección del
vector y más 7 en la dirección del
vector j y por supuesto estamos pensando
en una curva en dos dimensiones y que
está contenida en el plano entonces
vamos a vamos a hacer digamos la gráfica
una gráfica digamos muy general de esta
curva
y un poquito ahí está un eje el eje y y
aquí está el eje x el eje x y digamos
que nuestra curva a medida que avanza el
tiempo se mueve de esta forma ok esta es
nuestra curva r se mueve en esta
dirección
ok entonces lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo que será más bien un vídeo de
álgebra vectorial más que de cálculo es
poder ver un vector normal en la curva
en particular que sea unitario es decir
que tengamos un vector aquí en este
lugar
esto no se ve muy normal
ok que tengamos un vector aquí y vamos a
llamarle n y este vector debe ser
ortogonal es decir que sea que haga un
ángulo de 90 grados con la curva eso es
lo que estamos buscando pero bueno vamos
a revisar esto de cómo hacerlo porque
por ejemplo podríamos pensar mucho como
lo hacíamos en cálculo en de una
variable es decir queremos ver la
pendiente de una curva entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es fijarnos en un vector
digamos inicial aquí digamos este es r
uno para algún tiempo inicial y pensemos
ahora en un tiempo final digamos en este
otro vector r 2 ok estamos pensando que
a medida que avanzó el tiempo nos
movimos un poco más en la curva y
entonces tenía conseguimos este otro
vector r2 muy bien entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es pensar en el vector como una
forma de aproximar un vector tangente
pues es pensar
en
en la diferencia de estos dos no digamos
los el vector que se junta estas dos
puntas de la flecha y estamos pensando
en un vector tangente porque si tenemos
un vector tangente podemos obtener a
partir de eso
un vector perpendicular a él y que ya
sabemos hacerlo entonces por eso es que
estamos buscando hacer un vector
tangente déjenme hacerlo mucho mejor
porque nuestra primera aproximación
podría ser esta que sea considerar este
vector que pues podemos llamarle delta r
es decir el cambio en el en el vector de
posición y a partir de esto si nosotros
vamos aproximando r2 para que se vaya
apareciendo a r1 este vector delta r
deberá parecerse al final a nuestro
vector o más bien no deberá parecerse
sino que en el límite es decir cuando
esté r 12 juntas suficientemente cerca a
r 1 vamos a tener un vector tangente que
apuntará
en esta dirección ok a este a este
vector es el que vamos a llamarle de r a
este morado que es el vector tangente de
r es un vector tangente pueden haber
muchos verdad depende por ejemplo de la
magnitud o del sentido hacia donde estén
dirigidos pero bueno este es uno de los
vectores tangente
gente ahí está en este punto en
particular muy bien entonces como vamos
ahora a considerar nuestro vector porque
por ejemplo este vector tangente lo
podemos escribir como de r pues es
nuestro pequeño cambio en la dirección x
más un pequeño cambio en la dirección y
es verdad que está dado por la dirección
de los vectores y de j entonces un
vector
orton como como podríamos conseguir un
vector ortogonal a éste
pensemos supongamos que aquí tenemos
nuestro vector de r aquí está nuestro
vector de r y lo podemos descomponer en
sus dos componentes es en su componente
y en su componente j entonces por
ejemplo
vamos a hacer su componente en la
dirección j que es en la dirección
vertical
este vector ok hacia arriba aquí tenemos
a d y en la dirección del vector j y
también tenemos su componente su
componente en la dirección del vector y
es decir en la dirección x éste es de x
por iu y de hecho no tenemos que de x es
negativo porque apunta hacia la
izquierda verdad entonces una forma
digamos tenemos dos posibles vectores
ortogonales a este de verdad porque
tenemos este vector o tenemos este otro
vector para fines de este vídeo me voy a
quedar con el que apunta hacia la
derecha pero hay que tener muy claro que
podemos tener dos vectores normales
posibles vamos a concentrarnos sólo en
el derecho y voy voy a hacerlo en un
tamaño más grande para que quede más
claro entonces tenemos digamos aquí
nuestro vector de r este va a ser
de r
y dijimos que vamos a descomponer la
verdad en dos en sus dos en sus dos
componentes
y esto es un poquito complicado
rectas muy bien este me gustó mucho
entonces en esta dirección dijimos
tenemos a day en la dirección del vector
j y del otro lado vamos a tener vamos a
hacerlo igual con azul
en esta dirección tenemos de x en la
dirección del vector y entonces nosotros
sabemos muy bien que si yo quiero
obtener un vector ortogonal lo único que
tengo que hacer es cambiar e
intercambiar el papel de x y de belle y
algunos de ellos cambiarles el signo
entonces por ejemplo si yo cambio el
papel de belle es decir que no vaya en
la dirección vertical sino que ahora
vaya en la dirección horizontal vamos a
pintarlo aquí
y ahora está en la dirección horizontal
esto estamos pensando que es de iu pero
en la dirección del vector y y ahora si
yo quiero que mi vector normal apunte
digamos en esta dirección
necesito que de x ahora
apunte hacia arriba pero como están
apuntando hacia la izquierda y eso es
negativo y yo quiero que apunte hacia
arriba que es positivo voy a necesitar
cambiarle el signo si yo solo cambiara
de equis y lo multiplicó por jota como
de equis es negativo apuntaría hacia
abajo y eso no es lo que quiero yo
necesito que apunte hacia arriba
entonces vamos a poner aquí a de x de x
con un signo menos para que de esta
forma sea positivo y apunte en la
dirección vertical pero hacia arriba
entonces ya que tenemos estos dos ahora
la suma de estos dos nos debe dar un
vector normal
este es nuestro vector normal aquel que
tiene como componente ave y en la
dirección y ya menos de equis en la
dirección j y esto ya lo habíamos visto
en los vídeos de vectores y de
perpendicularidad y demás entonces este
vector normal que voy a llamarle a va a
ser igual a de i d y en la dirección
i
menos
menos de x en la dirección j y este es
uno de los vectores normales que yo
puedo encontrar todavía me falta
normalizar lo que significa que su norma
sea 1 entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
dividir entre la norma de a para que ya
tengamos una norma 1 y quien es la norma
de a quien es la norma o el tamaño de a
recuerden que hay gente que lo pone con
una sola barra a mí me gusta poner dos
barras porque así no nos confundimos con
el valor absoluto pero esto simplemente
es la raíz cuadrada de la suma de los
cuadrados de las componentes entonces
tenemos nuestra componente de x al
cuadrado que podría ponerle al menos
pero con el cuadrado
simplemente se cancela
de todo esto al cuadrado y que si
recuerdan muy bien cuando estamos
calculando longitudes longitudes de arco
y demás esto no es otra cosa más que un
cambio infinitesimal en la longitud de
arco y que lo denota vamos como de ese
muy bien entonces ahora ya podemos decir
que nuestro vector normal unitario en l
voy a poner este gorrito porque es
unitario
este vector normal va a ser el vector a
que no es otra cosa más que deje de ir
en la dirección y menos de x en la
dirección j pero dividido entre la norma
de a que como ya observamos es de s él
infinitesimalmente pequeño cambio en la
longitud de arco de esta forma pudimos
construir ya un vector normal unitario
sobre cualquier punto de la curva